el panorama es un brío en casa
tras las elecciones en las que el ex
Primer Ministro israelí benjamine tan
Yahoo lidera el conteo para muchos
palestinos los resultados No asombran ni
una sola vez las elecciones dieron como
resultado Un gobierno que se alinea con
los intereses del pueblo palestino por
lo tanto todos los gobiernos israelíes
han matado al pueblo palestino en cuanto
a la situación política no habrá cambios
todos siguen la misma política de
asesinato y guerra
el grupo es la misa jamás reaccionó a
los resultados que ubican al partido de
Ultra a la derecha populista y anti
árabe sionismo religioso como la tercera
fuerza política en Israel pronostican un
posible incremento en los
enfrentamientos
no esperamos un cambio en la política
accionista hacia nuestro pueblo excepto
una escalada de agresión contra nuestros
lugares sagrados y nuestro pueblo en
cisjordania y la franja de gaza
en Jerusalén los comicios dividen a los
ciudadanos algunos celebran la enorme
ventaja de la derecha
estoy feliz Felipe ver los resultados de
los escaños parlamentarios que son altos
la gente se despertó y vio lo que está
pasando en el país que no se puede
ignorar
[Música]
otros en cambio ven un retroceso me
siento muy decepcionada esperaba un
cambio esperaba que este gobierno se
mantuviera en el poder y se hiciera más
fuerte que tendríamos un futuro mucho
mejor y no Un gobierno de derecha
radical es una pena la cuarta elección
en Israel en menos de cinco años daría
como vencedor a una de las coaliciones
más derechistas para muchos podría
derivar en una escalada del conflicto